it's a well-known fact that disney
animators are some of the best in the
world
but we just found out about some hidden
messages in disney movies that never
made sense
until now
animators and writers love to hide
little hints and secrets within the
animation of disney movies
and audiences have been on the hunt for
these sneaky messages forever
hidden in plain sight for decades we
can't believe we didn't see these subtle
clues and secrets until today
one of our favorite characters in moana
is definitely heihei the rooster
even if he isn't the sharpest tool in
the shed
[Music]
it's okay early on during an encounter
with a villager
the man points out that heihei is
hilariously trying to eat a rock
and suggests that because of his lack of
intelligence should we maybe just
cook him in a hilarious detail we only
just noticed
later on in the movie heihei tries to
eat maui who is voiced by
yup the rock the gods have given me
we always found it a little weird that
in the little mermaid
prince eric believed that the
dark-haired version of ursula was the
real woman who saved him from drowning
but since we realized this new detail
the whole situation actually makes a lot
more sense
when ariel saves eric and sings part of
your world to him
he only wakes up enough to get one good
look at her and in that moment the sun
is shining brightly behind her
making it look like her hair is actually
dark brown
so it's a lot more believable that he
would have mistaken ursula in her human
form for ariel
[Music]
one tiny detail that we totally missed
from the very beginning of mulan
makes her victories over the huns even
more epic
during this song honor to us all mulan
is told that a girl can bring her family
great honor in one way
by striking a good match we always
assumed it meant finding a good husband
but there is a whole other way better
meaning
both of mulan's victories over the huns
first by causing an avalanche and second
by defeating shan yu using a firework
are from lighting fires aka striking a
good match
i am ready baby
we all know that mother gothel was the
real villain entangled
but one little moment we never noticed
really affirmed the one thing that
gothel
really loved about rapunzel after her
song mother knows best
she appears to kiss rapunzel goodbye and
tell her that she loves her the most
but if you look carefully you can see
that she's actually kissing rapunzel's
hair
and saying i love you to her golden
locks you
are not leaving this tower
ever there would have been no genie in
aladdin without the genius of robin
williams
he was such a part of the character that
they actually made a very sneaky
reference to the actor
in the animation of the movie when genie
is getting excited about finally being
free and heading off on vacation
he wears a bright yellow hawaiian shirt
and a goofy hat it was the exact same
outfit that williams wore
in a 1989 short film back to neverland
kristoff has some interesting beliefs in
frozen
and one that is so outlandish that the
filmmakers felt the need to clarify that
they don't agree with him
in the movie kristoff suggests that all
men eat their own boogers
which and at the very end of the credits
you can see that they actually included
a note from the production team
stating that they don't share his
viewpoints and honestly we're
glad to hear it all men do it ew
entangled the king and queen started an
annual lantern festival
after their daughter went missing hoping
that the lights would guide her home
when rapunzel sees the festival for the
first time she reaches out and pushes a
lantern into the sky
that lantern is actually the only one
with the royal symbol on it
meaning that it came from the palace
while subtle it hints that she is
finding her way back home
you wouldn't think that there would be
any connection between aladdin and mulan
but you'd be wrong in aladdin as aladdin
is trying to woo
jasmine with the help of genie disguised
as a bee he lists off a number of
desirable qualities like wonderful
magnificent glorious and punctual
punctual
punctual sorry years later in mulan
as she is writing down qualities that a
husband looks for in a wife
she ends with you guessed it punctual
disney animators are some of the best in
the world and it's all
in the details when it came to designing
all of the animals that maui would
transform into for moana
they made sure to hide in one very
specific element that
only the most eagle-eyed fans would
notice every time maui transforms
if you look closely you can see that his
hook is included somewhere in the
animal's markings
animation is a great way for filmmakers
to sneak important details into their
character designs that tell us so much
about who the character is
in the lion king one hidden message is
the way scar
was a warning all along most cats
including the big ones
keep their claws retracted until they
need to use them but if you look
carefully at scar
you'll see that his claws are always out
meaning that he's defensive and angry
and
always ready to fight and you couldn't
even dispose of them
ego from ratatouille starts out as just
a ruthless food critic
but one detail that we barely noticed
the first time around
shows just how much he has changed by
the end one of his famous lines is
if i don't love it i don't
swallow and at the beginning of the
movie
it's clear he hasn't enjoyed or
swallowed food in a really long time
but when we see him at the end after
having his life changed by the delicious
ratatouille he looks much healthier
happier and like he actually swallows
his food now
good for him
in one quick scene in the incredibles we
see two old men
talking about the super family and
complimenting them on being old school
it turns out that those two old men were
actually animated versions of real-life
disney animators frank thomas and ollie
johnston
who worked on snow white and the seven
dwarves in 1937.
they're line about preferring the old
school style refers to their older
non-computer-generated style of
animation and the throwbacks in the
incredibles that hearken back to that
time
that's the way to do it that's old
school
in the princess and the frog we met one
of the coolest
and creepiest disney villains ever dr
facilier
during his song friends on the other
side whenever his shadow is cast on the
patterned wallpaper
the pattern changes to a skull and bones
almost like an x-ray
because dr facilier is a witch doctor
and has connections with the dead
or friends on the other side as he puts
it the shadows are a subtle but super
creepy way of letting us know how
serious he is
don't you disrespect me little man
hercules is filled with amazing details
about ancient greek mythology
but this one flew right over our heads
when entering phil's crowded cabin
the teenaged hercules hits his head on a
big log hanging in the room
while it seems like a throwaway joke
it's actually a reference to another
greek myth
in which jason the captain of a ship
called the argo
met his end when the ship's mass broke
and hit him on the head
the argo yeah who do you think taught
jason how to sail
during the iconic song friend like me in
aladdin the genie sings a line that goes
like this
while alibaba had them 40 thieves
shahirazati had a thousand tails
we totally missed it when we were kids
but shahirazadi was actually a character
and narrator of a very well-known middle
eastern collection of short tales called
1001 nights
can you guess what one of those tales is
yup aladdin
now i know i'm dreaming we don't know
about you but we're suddenly overcome
with the urge to go back and re-watch
all of our favorite disney movies
we think we'll be starting with mulan we
can never get enough of our favorite
female warrior
what movie are you in the mood to watch